[Music]
this whole idea of Millennials being you
know this or that or the other I find it
ludicrous to be critical because you're
talking about the generation that was
the tipping point of why the Supreme
Court passed the the marriage you know
for gays you know they're the typically
they're the ones going are you kidding
me
they're the gender-fluid group I mean I
don't get that at all I mean it was hard
enough for me just to be a guy it alone
I'm gonna think that I'm fluid about
this I don't get it but it doesn't you
know disturb me a lot of my generation I
might as well been born on a different
planet than some of these pricks I feel
like they're dinosaurs really you're
gonna carry this stuff from the 50s on
with you this is really you're gonna
stand there in Congress you know that I
find more enraging but my real anger is
is that the they scream about these kids
and the the way in which they operate
and interact and socialize and the way
that they are and yet this is the
generation that had the that had the
phone's dropped on them and the computer
dropped on them and things changed and
so you've got a whole generation that is
living in a different world than we are
and they live on screens their whole
life is on a screen for most of them
when I was a kid I did LSD they said
well you you you can't really do a lot
of LSD so they made it illegal you know
and and then and they you know took it
away kind of you couldn't get really
good LSD after a while and but it was
like he can't do that that generation
turns around and drops on these kids
something that was just as potent as LSD
that phone and the amount of apps and
the amount of crap and the and the
computer it's the extension of the human
nervous system
it's a drug and it's not treated that
way and then think oh boy I can't
believe they're doing that well schmuck
it's just because you didn't because you
didn't do it and that's it and I think
that's going back to politics that's
part of the reason we live like we live
now that's imported the reason things
are the way they are it's we are in the
midst of a of a total sea change we've
gone from one age to another we have not
been we have not entered the new age and
we haven't left the old age but boy it's
it's happening and it scares the
out of a lot of people
[Music]